if you pause for a moment and ask
yourself what expectations you have for
the ending of one piece how likely do
you think it is that these expectations
will be fulfilled one piece is without a
doubt an amazing story that has
accompanied many of us for a very long
time yet in the far distance there lurks
a shadow on the horizon that is creeping
near an era with every chapter one sad
day in the hopefully not too close
future the one-piece manga will come to
an end and there will be an epic
showdown long-held mysteries will be
solved dreams fulfilled and everyone
will be happy or will they see the
tricky thing with the long-running
successful fandom is that once they come
to an end more often than not people
seem to be disappointed or even straight
out angry about a particular ending this
can be seen in tv shows like how many
mother in books like harry potter or in
manga as could be seen with naruto while
undoubtedly a lot of people liked the
ending to those particular stories many
if not most fans ended up disappointed
but why does this happen and will one
piece share their fate let's find out
while any story we enjoy brings certain
expectations with it one piece is a
special case in various ways the
one-piece manga has existed for over 20
years now and is still going strong its
continuous success and appeal have many
reasons but three of the story's main
pillars are oda's immense world building
the large and diverse cast of characters
as well as a very straightforward main
character with a very straightforward
goal so it is no wonder that the manga
has recently passed the mark of 450
million sold copies and has thousands of
readers following every new chapter you
could say that one piece is doing as
well as ever but exactly this success is
what has brought an unsatisfactory end
to many other stories the expectation
paradox so what exactly do i mean with
that when i talk about the expectation
paradox i propose that no matter what
the ending of one piece will be like and
no matter how good it will be it will be
disappointing for a huge number of
people in essence one piece cannot have
a great ending from a community
perspective
now why do i make such a ridiculously
sounding claim well mainly there are
three big reasons that make one piece a
top candidate for the expectation
problem and all three of them can be
kind of traced back to its immense
success let's have a look the first
reason is audience diversity oda's story
has accumulated an immense audience that
has been shaped for over more than two
decades one piece is definitely not
simply a story for kids you have young
readers and old readers readers who have
grown up with the story and readers who
just recently discovered it as well as
readers from different cultural
backgrounds while this fact in itself is
simply amazing and speaks for the
greatness of the story it also means
that there exists very different
expectations in the community simply
based on how old you are how long you've
been with the story and what cultural
beliefs and values you have a 15 year
old japanese boy that just started
reading the manga will expect completely
different things from the story than for
example a 28 year old american girl that
has grown up with it both enjoy all the
arcs and the characters and the new
chapters but when it comes to certain
moments and in particular to the ending
both will want completely different
things to happen
one might expect an amazing fight with a
clean happy ending while the other might
want a more serious and subversive or
dramatic ending fact is the audience
diversity of one piece leads to many
people with distinct and specific
expectations for the story's conclusion
the second reason is the incredible
one-piece community and since you're
watching this video right now for better
or worse you're a part of it while i
myself obviously enjoy this community
immensely and love participating in it
it's a big problem in terms of
expectation buildings for fans while
making and watching discussions analysis
and theories of the story are amazingly
fun and in itself is in no term a bad
thing it contributes heavily to people
being dissatisfied with the story going
any other direction than what they
expected and this will be especially the
case once the story wraps up people have
been speculating and theorizing about
the ending of one piece for ages and
have built giant arguments for their
cases seeing these expectations not
fulfilled might make the true ending of
one piece feel disappointing to them the
third reason is pretty much simply time
as mentioned before the manga has
existed for 22 years and even the anime
is celebrating its 20th birthday this
year time does a lot to a story some
people have had years to build their
expectations for certain events others
have changed their taste with the time
and oda himself has shifted his style a
little here and then while a lot of
things happen in the story itself in the
past decades we have heard countless
theories discussions and analysis of
every aspect of one piece to the point
where it sometimes can seem hard to
believe that we haven't heard the true
ending yet somewhere in some long lost
subreddit while the time aspect of one
piece is something i personally more
than love about the manga due to the
years of losing myself in a still
developing world it has set the
expectations for many people in a very
specific direction now those three
reasons the diverse audience the lively
community as well as the time frame of
the story all lead to the conclusion
that it's basically impossible for oda
to write an ending to one piece that
will be seen as great by the majority
this effect will be additionally
strengthened by the nature of ending
itself even if you're happy with the
ending simply the fact that one piece
will be over will add a bit of taste to
it but while it might be inevitable for
a huge part of the community to have
their expectations disappointed in the
end i now want to tell you while you as
an individual should not be afraid of
the final chapter of one piece first of
all you have to find out if you are
someone that tends to have set or
flexible expectations the easiest way
around the expectation paradox in the
first place for you is if you tend to
have a rough idea of what you would like
to see but in general just follow along
with the story and enjoy in whatever
direction it goes if this is the case
for you great you will most likely be
fine since i really do expect oda to
come up with a great ending from a pure
storytelling perspective another type of
person would be someone that has very
set expectations in mind when it comes
to the story wrapping up you expect that
certain things will happen in a certain
way and not differently since that is
how you personally want things to go for
your favorite characters while this is
in no way any better or worse than the
other it is very likely that you will
have a hard time once the last chapter
comes out since the chance of your hat
cannon hitting the jackpot are rather
slim to avoid that it might be worth
trying to go a middle way basically
having certain expectations in mind but
being open for other outcomes as well
that maybe don't fulfill your
expectations but bring closure in a
satisfactory way will it be happy and
heroic will it be dramatic and
subversive or will the ending simply be
a really big plot twist if you follow
one piece until now i'm sure you have
overcome previous expectations before
anyway but most importantly though it
doesn't look like one piece will end
anytime soon so you can simply enjoy
everything around the story for many
more years to come if you want to see
how the expectation paradox plays out
beforehand though you can just come back
to this video later this year after you
watch the final of game of thrones and
then let me know how your experience was
with that ending in any case i
personally am convinced that one piece
will get the ending it deserves i just
hope it will not be over too soon